カメラのレンズを変えました
こんにちははじめしゃちょーです
…広くなったなぁ
はいというわけで今日の動画は、
皆さんですね、
…とか、
…ってためる人たまに居ませんか
なんかこう物事を大きく表現する際に使われる言葉として
…とかあると思うんですよ
この言葉を付け足すだけで
すごくその物事が大きく見えます
例えば可愛い人がいたら、
ｶﾜ(・∀・)ｲｲ!!
って言うんじゃなくて、
…とか
とか言った方が
可愛さのレベルがねぇ、
一段階も二段階も上がるんですよ
ですが！その後さらに可愛い人がいたら
「すごく可愛い」って言っても
同じレベルになっちゃうんですよ、その人の方が可愛いのに
…っていうときに使われる表現が、
すっっっっっ…
…っごく可愛い
ほんっっっっっ…
ｩﾍﾞｧｯﾍｪ
っとに可愛い
って言うように
って三段階に分かれると思うんですよ
で僕も大げさな表現する時に勿論それ使いますし、
皆さんも、なんか本当にすごいものを表現したいときは
〇〇っっっっ…
…っ
っていう表現を使うと思います
で今日はこの
っっっっ…
の限界に迫ってみようと思います
この企画、多分僕と付き合いが長い人とか
よくしてる人がやると、
「あ～なんかこいつふざけてんなぁ」
と思って馬鹿にされるんで
なんか最近やっと話し始めた
畑の新メンバーのテツヤと、
畑の新メンバーのオーディションに落ちたまたぞうくん
その二人がここにいるとすごいなんか
三人気まずくなると思うんで、
そのまだそんな仲良くない三人で並んで僕が
「すっごく」の小さい「っ」をどこまで伸ばせるかどうか
ちょっと実験してみようと思います
さぁそしてですね、この焼きそばパンが
めっっっっっ…
…っちゃ美味しいんですよ
というわけでこの焼きそばパンの美味しさを
ターゲットに伝えていきたいと思います
ではいこう ( ・`ω・´)ｷﾘｯ
まだちょっと、ここ座っといて
テ）えこれ今日の動画ですか？
は）たぶん今日の
は）これどかして～
は）･∵.Σ(ﾟД´(へぇっふ!!!!!!
は）んなぁ
は）よぉし、撮るかぁ
三人）……
ま）気まずい
は）気まずいな
は）ちょっと、畑受かった人と受かってない人で
対決させようと思ってさ
wwwwwww
は）ちょ焼きそばパンだけ食っていい？
なんかお昼先にいただきますほんと、ちょ待ってすぐ食うから
テ）はい
は）うぅん！！
ま）あ止まった？
テ）で僕らだけ動いてる感じですよね
ま）あれっ
テ）はじめさん
はじめさん
はじめさんｗ
ま）再生っ(*ﾟДﾟ)σ凸
テ）だめだぁ
テ）何かが絶対トリガーになってるはず…
なんでぇ、
テ）なんだろうなぁ
(吹き飛んでいくまたぞうの「めっちゃ 」)
テ）いや多分絶対あれですよ、
テ）なんか言うと動き出す、みたいなやつなんすよ
テ）絶対そうだ
は）ﾃﾞｭｸｼ( ∩'ω' )=͟͟͞͞⊃ ’,;’;
ま）:(；ﾞﾟ'ωﾟ'):ｸﾞﾌｯ
テ）やべぇ難しいwww
なんだ
ま）朝ですよ～
ま）やばいこのままでは
ま）はじめさんをずっとこのまま
止めてしまうことになる…
テ）wwww
テ）永久に動かなくなっちゃいますよ
テ）ちょ、またぞうさんそれずるいですよ、
動かなくなるの
ま）www
二人）wwwww
テ）置き去りはダメっすよさすがにwww
キツイっすキツイっす
テ）へぇー
は）うん、
ま）ほぉん
は）うめぇ、めっちゃ美味かったこれ
は）んいやぁ、止まってない止まってない
テ）いや止まってましたよ
は）いや止まってないよ多分
は）焼きそばパン好き？
テ）まぁ好きです
ま）好きです
は）あぁ好きなんだ～、そうなんだぁ
テ）え、じゃあちょっと言ってみてください…ｗ
は）ﾃﾞｭｸｼ( ∩'ω' )=͟͟͞͞⊃ ’,;’;
ま）あぁ、これがトリガー…
テ）多分…
ま）(ﾟДﾟ;)ﾋﾞｸｯ
テ）テツヤぁ
めっちゃデブやん！
テ）めっちゃ太ってるんすよ
は）め、めっちゃデブじゃん
どうすんのそれ、ダイエットしなよ
テ）やちょっと、したいですねぇやっぱり
は）うぅ～ん
三人）………
ま）美味しいっすか？
は）うまいうまいうまい
テ）どれくらい美味しいっすか？
は）いやもう
ま）おいぃい（；＾ω＾）
テ）wwwwww
テ）やっぱ「め」がトリガーなんだなぁ
は）･∵.Σ(ﾟД´(へぇっふ!!!!!!
テ）ふははははwww
ま）そこまず考えた方が、解決の糸口あるかもしんないっすね
三人）………
テ）僕らが呼ばれてるってこと、
には絶対何かしらの意図があって
ま）( ﾟдﾟ) ｡_｡) ﾟдﾟ) ｡_｡)ｳﾝｳﾝ
テ）セーフ！w
テ）そうっすね
は）あれぇ？？(；・∀・)ﾊｯ?